not a moment too soon as the flood
waters continue to rise in the town of
chezina a young child is saved just in
time and handed over to rescue workers
a moment of Hope amid the devastation
elsewhere in the town as the water
reached as high as the tops of buildings
coast guards managed to pull this man to
safety the only means of Escape through
a small window in the roof
24 municipalities have been flooded
unfortunately all the rivers of Amelia
Romania have overflowed their
embankments causing flooding
the torrential rain across Emilia
romagna forced the swollen Banks of 14
rivers to burst flooding the surrounding
areas cutting off roads and rail links
even in the regional Capital bologna
where streets in the city center were
inundated with hardly any protection to
keep the Rushing Waters at Bay
local Mayors warned people not to travel
or approach areas close to rivers and to
keep away from basements and ground
floors of buildings
this is the second time this month in
this region where people have been
killed as a result of extreme weather
conditions
a state of emergency has once again been
declared with the interior Minister
Matteo piantedozi visiting to see the
damage already so extensive that the
Emilio romagna Grand Prix at the imela
circuit was postponed to focus on Rescue
efforts in the region
the rise of extreme weather-related
events in Italy has been documented by
the government's environment agency in
the past decade alone record high
temperatures and severe storms have
risen five-fold yet little has been done
to mitigate the risks in a country that
is already especially vulnerable to such
climate events Sonic Gallego Al Jazeera